ええええええ
me
皆さんこんにちはじゃあ
jo 四季の森運営委員会の委員長しております式高2年の西岡と申します
京王色のボディ運営委員会というのは三重県にある
掲揚式の思い出も地づくりを通して
人形や森林生態系
環境問題などもいに関する様々なことを学ぶ
suke 八尾志紀もいツアーを行なう委員たいです
これから高校生が林業学ぶ良い
について話したいと思います
まず普段の方についてお話します
夏には昨日太さや高さを測ったしています
春には枝を打ちをしたり
間伐をしたりしていますではなぜはるばる見えまで行ってそのようなことをするの
でしょうか
実はこの方に志木校の ob である
吉田善三郎さんがおよそ20年前に施行へ寄贈してくださったものなんです
それいこ式高生が中心となって毎年年2回春と夏にこの文字を訪れ
活動をしています
ここで皆さんに問題です
四季合成が30人およそ3時間かけてキー麻子の木材
一体全部で五回のでしょうか
例えば時給1000円がと仮定しましょう30人で3時間無かっ9万円いかがですか
高いと思いますか
高いですよねん
じゃあお前にはどうでしょう
ちょっとならないはいじゃ1万円ではどうでしょ
はい満載だったいいかなと
実はこの木台全部で全部で2000円です
安いですよねえ
僕も初めて聞いた時を通しました
僕自身この木を聞いだしたわけですから強い衝撃を覚えました
寛実はこの木材間伐材なんです
干ばつには声だけの労力が買うのにも関わらず
間伐材きたはとてもとても安い値段でしか取り引きされません
実際
家が出荷できるようになるまでに50年で233万円もかかるんです
高いですよね
赤い
でも間伐には
お金や銅よくに変え会えない家事があるんです
それはもいの全体の価値を上げる
好きな思いに愛機は
全て僕たちが高校生名前場合によっては僕たちは生まれマイカー感じ最適なんです
この写真は僕たちはうまゆこおよそ17年前に
と開いた写真です今からじゃあ全然予想もつかない
2型ですよね
自分が昨日て遊佐かといってそれが自分の二役ならないん
52的とかそういうものを完全に超越したものでありながら同時産業として
良寿しているそれが尋常なんです
投影し党員将来世代を越えて頭いい将来を見つめ続けることができる産業
その考えると人行ほど過去や見合いへ思いを馳せることできる参与他にはないのでは
ないでしょうか
padi
少し日本の林業についてお話ししましょう
いっ
木材の価格は1980年から
徐々に減少の傾向にあります
原因として大きく2つ ii ますひとつは狂気もう一つは需要です
供給に感謝ですが皆さんもご存知かと思いますが
海外の違法伐採によってもたらせる木材が大量に流入し木材の価格が低下しました
じゃあ需要の方ではどうでしょう
1973年には一人値一時本 a 棟の木を使っていたのは大外へ
お願いですねまあ2012年にはデー0.55日本へと半減してます
米皆さんのマーニーも着3期のものはあると思いますが以前より減ったのではない
でしょうか
例えば木造の住宅
今では年には前にありませんよねー
人形はこのような需要の低下と供給の過剰によって苦境に立たされています
しかし
僕林業はあーたの速名をもちろんになりました
供給の面ですああ
海外のに頬張っ性が急速な新人の減少をもたらしたために国際社会はそのような伐採
できる分
聞いたさえ短期を使わないようにと
適切な感情された森林カー出された気に
人ションをつけましたそれが fsc 認証です
先進国を中心にこの陣所普及しツアーに慶應義塾も
自分の持っても良いがその銀賞火災ように努力をしています
子様の面に関してですが木材をそのまま気を船はなく加工数技術も高まっています
例えばこの直行集成材亜洲定番
清瀬んよ
クロスさせることによって鉄筋コンクリート並みの強度と
ティナー4-10柔軟が加工が行事ちゃ言うんです
これ欧米で普及し始めていて
マンションが建つ具合今日の元木材なんです
すごいですよね
すごい
まだ
環境問題としての環境対策へ高台策としての利用もん
注目されています
新鋭は木材として使用せずともそこに畦滝で
co2を削減してくれますがそうしてできた木材を
燃料として使うことによって化石燃料を使わずに済みますし
化石燃料よりも co2の発生を抑えることができるのです
すごいんですよね
すごい
僕たちがこの式の思いで活動できんが
高校生であるわずか3年間
それは
食人をして間伐をして大きくな滝を聞い出すといった100年50年にもわたる長い
行程のほんの一米しかありません
しかし
実際に山に入って作業したに
木材製材所はバイオマス発電所などの実際に気を使われる現場を見ることで
日本の人形や森林の現場に実際に身を置くことができるんです
このような体験を通して
地球温暖化などといった地球規模ん大きな問題に対して現場感覚を持った施工が可能に
なんです
もちろん高校生だから楽しい事もします
缶瓶を漕いでみたりバームクーヘンをつくったりすんです
このバウムクーヘンの神に光って行き先ほど観ていただいた間伐材です
まさにバームクーヘンですよね
四季思いツアー今年20周年を迎えます
これを実行慶應義塾高校が70周年らしいのねー
100周年を迎える光式のモニターを50周年を迎えます
次の舞の木は
柱などに使われる立派な気になっていることでしょう
実は慶應義塾はこの式の思いだけではなく全国に森を持っているです皆さんも
森のサインああん森の数に関わってみてはいかがでしょうか
ないか
関わってみたいそうですよねぇー
僕たちは机上の空んではなく
現場感覚を持ったし小屋
遠い将来までを見据えた思考が大切です
そのような中で
どーん
が消えて泣けます
そのようなわけで
8位森林家の育成や活用に携わる人魚は長い産業の地道なか
活動の積み重ねです
そのような人業実際に体験して辞退することで僕たちは仲間達とともに
将来園役立つ当院少年見据える
力を手に入れることが出来るんです僕たちもこれを目指してこれからも活動を続けて
いければなと思いますご静聴ありがとうございました